after nearly 7 years in jail former
Philippine Senator Laya De Lima is free
and home a small crowd of wellwishers
greeted her as soon as she stepped out
of the
airport Del Lima had said many times
before visiting her alien 91-year-old
mother is one of the first things she'd
do on leaving detention when she came
out of her mother's room she had this to
say I feel so good I feel so great
Christmas celebrations are early in the
Del Lima household for justice and
freedom a local trial court had granted
her bail after a judge found testimonies
had failed to prove the Lima engaged in
the illegal drug trade she'd been
cleared in two other cases the previous
government under former president
Rodrigo duerte had accused her of
collecting drug money from convicts to
fund her senatorial campaign she's
maintained they were fabricated because
she dared investigate DET ttis War drugs
other victims of the ttis anti-drugs
campaign have been forced to turn to the
international criminal court for justice
the Lima says she's ready to help my
resolve is still so strong in terms of
Seeking Justice for the thousands of
victims of the murderous Drug War under
the previous
regime but for now she says she just
wants to make up for lost time with
loved
ones while the celebration is going head
here in Laya de Lima's home region she
says she hasn't forgotten that the trial
isn't over but she says she's always had
Faith she'll be Vindicated no matter how
long it takes Barn below Al jazer from
the be region in the
Philippines make sure to subscribe to
our channel to get the latest news from
Al
jaaz